[Applause]
sports as an antidote for violent
extremism and the need to protect major
sporting events against terrorism
that's one of the major themes of this
year's u.n counterterrorism office forum
in doha in partnership with the qatari
government
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
thank you once again for the opportunity
to deliver a message to the
international community on the
importance of sports role as a vehicle
and a continuing global battle of
countering extremism the timing couldn't
be more crucial as the country
approaches the final stages of
preparation for the 2022 fifa world cup
amid regional turmoil and international
tensions
but the scope of the forum is much wider
its purpose is to discuss how to provide
the necessary technical assistance
for more than 50 countries in their
fight against terrorism and violent
extremism
qatar has provided the funding since it
signed a partnership agreement with the
un in 2018.
the partnership agreement between the
state of qatar and the un's office of
counter-terrorism signed in 2018 with
the aim to support the office's
strategic initiative for the period of
five years from 2019 to 2023 has laid
the foundation for a broad-based
long-term partnership qatra's
contribution of 15 million dollars puts
it at the top of the list of
contributors to the office
qatar says it wants the partnership to
be an example for other countries
it's important to diversify the support
that comes from other member states from
different regions to university this is
a key partnership this is a key entity
within the un system and we need to
support supported through through of
course supporting the core contributions
to to to your city and of course
strengthening the partnership through
the five offices that has been
established under your leadership
there's a renewed focus on security as
the 2022 world cup draws closer the
first such event in the middle east
where nearly half a dozen countries are
rocked by internal conflict and
instability muhammad
[Music]